this weekend the world of counter strike
watched as
two online era giants faced off in a
five map final
for the ages danish underdogs heroic
emerged victorious
further cementing them and their
opponents as
world-class competitors whose hard work
can't be discredited
but as anyone who actually watched the
finals will tell you
it wasn't just that heroic one it was
how they won heard about the 1v4 with
the p250
i haven't heard of that how does it go
chad it was a pretty important round it
was for
the title he managed to sneak his way
all the way through the back lines here
and shoot shiro in the back of the head
and what did he do after that that's the
up and kills the guy ct oh my god he's
knifed him
okay so if you've ever watched me sit
here and gush about cs go then you
already know the drill please please
please slap the sub button
like the video and turn on notifications
so you never miss an opportunity to
feast your eyes on how pretty i am
okay so this past weekend esl pro league
season 13
came to a conclusion and what a
conclusion it was
against every expectation the final four
came down to a bunch of so-called
onliners who'd been hustling for over a
year to crack into the upper echelon of
competitive counter-strike
heroic gambit ninjas and pajamas
and the bison rushing beauties on furia
the thing is these dudes didn't just
make top four they coasted to it
clapping the biggest names in cs go
along the way
with gambit and heroic going undefeated
until the grand finals
hell furia even two owed astralis in the
quarters
taking trains 16 to [ __ ] two
nades are going to hurt two but are
still going forward not even taking down
clay oh my god he's gonna get another
one
glocks is all that surrounds him
a harrowing loss but a spectacular
victory
headshots from magisk delaying the
inevitable is confirmed 16-2
but the real showstopper came in the
finals
now for those who don't know gambit vs
heroic was heralded to be an
absolutely sick face-off two undefeated
underdogs whose respective journeys to
the top
had been long arduous and altogether
pretty unexpected the tldr on gambit of
course is that since being led by zeus
to their
awesome fluky one in a million major
victory in 2017
they had done well [ __ ] all
that is until about midway through last
year when covet hit
everything went online and gambit got
back hobbit one of their star fraggers
from the 2017 major run
and that's when these cis cinderellas
really began to take the world of cs go
by storm as for heroic most of the story
is focused around
long time competitors slash analyst
slash all-around
sweetheart katie after years of failing
to get his big break on a myriad of
rosters
and a few instances where he was just
straight up screwed over
this opping igl's time finally came
when quarantine enabled he and the
up-and-comers on heroic he'd been given
license to lead
to grind their way to the top now their
first massive achievement came in august
of last year
when they emerged victorious from the
european division of esl one cologne
this is the first cologne for bob kadian
texas and they're the last team standing
unbelievable
absolutely incomprehendable
winning a big trophy in counter-strike
was not in my cabinet before this
2015 i was on the desk for cologne only
dreaming about
reaching a final or getting that fire in
the tournament
now we are the champions honestly it's
unbelievable
what a road for this team what a road
for me
i'm so speechless man this is i don't
know
i didn't expect this of course lots of
people were quick to dismiss that
achievement echoing the all too
obnoxious disclaimer
that online results deserve to have an
asterisk beside them
but kadian didn't give a [ __ ] why
because it was his name on the side of
the cologne trophy not those cretans on
the hltv forums
well i have a esl one cologne trophy
that don't
and looking at all the other teams
playing i don't think anyone is not
taking these situations series
we know that corona might be affecting
this scene for the next
couple of months still so no one is just
like leaning back everyone is fighting
the hardest to win
i know that by watching all the other
teams as well and you gotta make
the most of what you you have right you
can't only eat what what is served and
right now online c is a serve then we
we're definitely grabbing our part of
the that meal as well
needless to say the longer that this
so-called online era went on
the better that these teams who'd found
their groove in this era started to do
before long gambit were besting vertice
pro
in the iem world championship and more
and more
youngans were eeking their way into
hltv's global top 30.
by the time the playoffs of esl pro
league season 13 rolled around
it was starting to become apparent that
these onliners were
a force to be reckoned with that if
these so-called
real tier 1 rosters didn't buckle down
and take
online play seriously they were at risk
of getting left behind
which brings us to the grand finals
where two untouchable bands of
up-and-comers put on
what was essentially the greatest show
we could have asked for
now there was actually a fair bit of
hype around these finals i even debated
slapping a gold heroic sticker on my op
if they won
which like i have to now right to start
heroic get bodied on inferno and it
looks like we're going home
early but wait they mount an unthinkable
comeback
and somehow take inferno they ride that
momentum
straight into vertigo where they get
absolutely
[ __ ] on like 16-3 [ __ ] ladies and
gentlemen
we've got a series heroic proceed to
take train
28 to 26 only to
lose overpass 16 to 10
like what lo and behold it all comes
down to mirage
where after literally hours of coin
flippy chaos
heroics simply run away with it before
we even blink heroic is up
15 to six and even though canadian is in
a 1v4
in an eco round no one actually doubts
that they will take it
little did we know we were about to
witness what is quite literally a
contender
for the sickest clutch in the history of
csgo
heard about the kdm1v4 with the p250 i
haven't heard of that how does it go
chad
well it's a pretty important round it
was for the title
he actually won it with just that that
p250 i can't believe nobody was looking
and he managed to sneak his way all the
way through the back lines here and
shoot shiro in the back of the head
right and what did he do after that
that's nuts so so he actually shoots the
or from the back of the head without
anyone looking
that's the op and kills the guy ct oh
yeah ah
yeah oh oh my god he's knifed him and
he's gotten away with the orb i'm
starting to get nervous
there's no way there's no way kaden you
can't win pro league like this
you can't win pro league like this no
way
exiles left 40 seconds and the bombs on
a take your time son you're about to
make the play of your career
[Music]
oh my god 30 seconds now axel's on ramp
he's got 30 seconds to think this one
through
a knife kill
he's thinking about jumping though he
just has to hit this shot and he's done
it for heroic
the leader calling well above his ears
clearing corners
and i just can't believe it 40 of their
team
only together since february
i'm with nothing but a p250 chad i'm in
disbelief
now for those who aren't especially
familiar with counter-strike
you need to understand this play for all
intents and purposes
is impossible canadian has a p250
no armor the bomb is smack dab in the
middle of a and he's up against
four fully armed ct's this can't be done
and yet somehow some way
he pulls it off how well
for starters the knife kill now to be
clear
cadian didn't do this for the bm or for
the style points
he did it for the money for those who
don't know getting a knife kill in cs go
nets you fifteen hundred dollars which
is more than any other type of frag
ensuring that canadian can buy an off
the next round
it just so happens that because he opted
to knife the stairs player instead of
shoot him
he was able to pick up his op now had he
chosen to
shoot the opera instead of knifing him
he would have had to close
the gap before being able to pick up his
gun which
in all likelihood wouldn't have been
possible this way he just
emerges from the frag already holding it
next
he hugs stairs anticipates the swing and
sure enough because nafini is succumbing
to both panic
and greed boom since he already saw the
third guy
swing from ticket to triple he rips off
two perfectly placed wall bangs
and would you look at that he's gotten
it down to a 1v1
he molly's firebox for good measure
holds it
and since nothing's there assumes that
the guy has to be ramp
he sneaks a peek on him holding tetris
on an info jump
and well the rest is quite literally
history also if you haven't seen it this
is what the winning moment looked like
at the heroic camp
warning it will give you chills
[Applause]
it has been a very long time since i
have seen the counter-strike community
just collectively declare
seconds after a play happened that it
had already been etched into the
annals of this franchise's long and
storied
history sometimes you see a play and
just know
in fact people are already pestering
valve to slap a graffiti on stairs
commemorating the play of course it
seems unlikely that that'll actually
happen
since in the past graffitis have always
been reserved for plays that happened
during majors
specifically olaf's burning defuse
fanatics 4 man mid-peak coldzera's
jumping 4k
and simples falling off still it could
be a great way for valve to show people
that they are still engaged in cs
and a great way to pay respect to what
esl are doing for the game in the modern
era
also it feels like we're kind of just
due for one since it's been like
five years since the last one was at it
i will also say though that it doesn't
need to be a graffiti per se
freiberg's via adamo on inferno for
instance is a non-spray painted tribute
to his overall reputation as
counter-strike's king of banana
there's also the olaf boost sign or
dosia's grenade poster
they could certainly do something along
those lines but the coolest thing about
the canadian clutch was how it brought
seemingly every eye in esports onto
counter-strike
seconds after it happened it went viral
virtually everyone i follow on social
media regardless of what esport they're
engaged in it couldn't help but be
absolutely floored at how insane it was
which
goes to show just how awesome and
impactful this online era that
everyone's been so quick to write off
has actually been like it or not there
does seem to be a sort of
changing of the guard happening right
now a lot of experienced
established juggernauts are struggling
to stay consistent
and every time a furious or a virtus pro
wipes the floor with them
people start spouting yeah but it's
online
and while that's not to say that things
won't pick up again for them when we're
back on land
what's their excuse gonna be if they
don't what do these serious
s-tier teams say if we go back to lan
and they continue to get run over by
these onliners
we let them get the better of us when it
didn't matter and now that it does
we simply forgot how to beat them to be
clear
i am not suggesting that navi or
astralis or whoever
all of a sudden suck that would be
ridiculous
what i am saying is that you can't just
write off a year and a half of results
and assume that things will pick up
where they left off
the world of counter-strike is changing
in fact it has changed
and these top-tier teams need to ensure
that they're keeping up
don't get me wrong i am dying for lands
to come back and will jump with joy the
day that they do
but i'm also having a ball watching as
competitors like kadian
and rosters like heroic gambit and all
the others who've worked so hard slap
everyone in sight
so before you start crapping on the
current state of competitive cs and
jotting down asterixes beside all the
results
show some respect because this era has
given us one of
the sickest plays in the history of the
game
you may not like it but this is sure as
[ __ ]
what peak performance looks like
also there's this work stack we have now
like legit like there's like guys who
play they're all in silver all
five of them are in silver i played once
with them it was rough
it was that sounded mean it was not
that's not what happened i think i don't
know if i told you yeah
they're all silver four silver and my
rank is a lot higher so
it didn't pair us against one high rank
and four silvers it paired us against
five gold novas
so which is rough right because it's
five players who are better than my four
players but
not better than me and so it it's rough
like yeah it's a tough
tough scenes as you would say tough
scenes on on the b
apartments tough scenes on the b
apartments not
not quite unthinkable just just tough